part
on when I come
here I'm really I'm going to open it but
this is what I'm
pushing I'm not here and pulling this
hand so if you pay
attention it's not open like you
guys it's it's kind of pinched right I
you can
so it's pinching
here and dropping here and then I push
this hand this hand will only drop as
much as this lowers in the ten con it's
not cutting down that would be pulling
and as I said as I'm trying to pull
in and when I ten con they're pulling
away from each
other well I push
in it's moving with me okay so I know it
looks like I'm you know doing that crazy
thing but remember he can't pull out his
hand so if I go here is a pretty weak I
adhesion you see because it's so
parallel to the to his arm we're almost
like
this so but when I when I try to close
this in that fashion then this hand is
here and now they're not they're not
parallel his pulling out is working
against that you
see here it's
not okay so the mechanism isn't this
cuts down it's that this pushes in this
is doing this
so when you're
here this this feeling but you need that
contact right come around this one and
now all can just be here because that's
where I need to be for the brake I can't
be down here for
it okay the distal end gives me way more
leverage and it gives me this ledge that
I can push down on with my bicep
you see to push down not just in here
just
in so you want to be here
boom you see more
trap pushing
in on top is it there's a Twist right
there's a Twist like that from being
here there it is again every time
[Music]
okay you're going to have to come close
cuz uh what you can see that your ego
tripartite mind wants to push this down
right cuz you want to get that shoulder
down but I can't push his shoulder I I
can't push his shoulder I'm going to do
it with two hands I cannot push your
shoulder down
and that all gets compounded as he goes
up he gets to use his leg strength I
can't push it down you have to follow
the 90° fluctuation drill you can't push
this down and you're going to get him
here that's what everyone
dreams okay so you're trying what you're
doing
instead is pushing this
hand in you you see you're pushing this
hand this hand in
okay so you're not cutting on his
shoulder you cut on his shoulder you
make him even stronger because you're
closer to his legs you want to be on the
elbow just like on
ikur out here away from his legs not on
the shoulder I push on the shoulder he's
going to get
up okay this is where your angled
disturbances and your leverage you're
just doing it with one hand now so it
just rests here some of you are
here some of you are here as there's no
joint there okay it's right right in
here which is exactly where the thumb
and the finger go in EA and now doing it
with my knife edge okay and I've pushing
this this part
forward and as I rotate so he he tries
to he tries to stand
up okay so which way do I have to take
him forward
forward you see as he tries to stand up
I take it Forward he tries to stand up
I'm taking it forward so I can't do it
here I know it looks like it but this is
just
contestation okay this hand is just here
waiting it's not doing anything it's not
pulling us
down okay it's just here Bo that's
it but I have to move him forward he
tries to get up I move it
forward okay this all I'm doing and as
he
steps as he steps around to regain his
balance right what energy is he bringing
up
Yin or Yong there's only two y okay so
that helps my internals right so I'm not
necessarily bringing them in with waist
torque it's qua so as as we're
here okay he's going to try to go
up I have remember we just kind
of for the sake of discussion said I get
30° of cloth
was it 30 sure okay so when when he goes
up you're going to feel the Yang you
internalize the Yang and that's what
moves him around so he goes up and you
moving and you're just doing that that's
just what's happening he goes around you
just keep projecting he's throwing
himself into it and I'm roring It
Forward at 90° and he
falls it's not me going like
this okay
now I'm here boom that's it there's your
adhesion right here you're stuck on it
okay you know you want to take him down
you know he doesn't want to go down you
feel his inertia if if there was if he
was
falling he'd be in he's not falling he's
young okay and that's what you keep
bringing
around with this motion
here and I know it looks like I'm taking
them down but I'm not I'm just staying
up with him you understand that
difference I'm just staying up with
[Music]
him not lowering my weight to take him
down can you see it now okay
last point we'll
cover is the 225 to
270° okay that he won't truly get
unstable and certainly not here I've
seen a lot of that where you take him
where his head is going
okay not here
either not here
either he has to come past his is
180 plus 45°
minimum or 90°
maximum
okay
so if you're
looking there there he
is he can't go here if I throw him here
well if I bring him forward for let's do
the worst one
I bring him forward he's just going to
brace and now you're and that
happens at every
subsequent angle till I get past it's
when it gets
hard
okay so you have to think about that as
you're
going in the
technique okay it doesn't matter oh if
your
okay try it